Space is big.
Like.
Really big.
Of the many probes, orbiters, and surveyors
the people of Earth have sent into space to
explore our solar system, an uncomfortable
number have been lost.
Lost spacecraft make people crazy, engineers
included.
We spend millions of dollars to send these
things to a very specific place, how do we
just… lose them?
What happens if we lose things in space?
If they’re millions of miles away and are
far too small to see with telescopes, what
do we do?
Usually, lost means loss of contact.
It doesn’t always mean we don’t know where
something is.
Engineers and mathematicians calculate the
trajectory of everything we send into space.
But those calculations aren’t perfect (sorry,
y’all), so if a spacecraft stops talking
to us at some point, it can drift away from
our calculations… which brings us back to:
Space is big.
The losses range from the Soviet, Zond 3 which
sent pictures of the far side of the moon
for the first time, but was lost on the way
to Mars; to NASA’s infamous Mars Climate
Orbiter which got lost because NASA’s teams
mixed up metric and english units; and even
a Japanese probe named Akatsuki which was
lost trying to orbit Venus… … but, then
it was found again!
And being found again is the sweetest in space.
The ‘verse is scary for little probes just
trying to get where they’re going.
So, when we’re sending spacecraft to Mars,
Pluto, or even just down to the International
Space Station, we give them lots of ways to
tell us where they are.
The Mars Science Laboratory, that carried
Curiosity to Mars, had multiple antennas to
communicate with Earth and other spacecraft
already at Mars that could relay the signals
back.
The Curiosity rover itself also has multiple
antennas to talk to spacecraft in Mars’
orbit, as well as Earth directly through the
Deep Space Network.
Again, Engineers work really hard and design
spacecraft to make sure that if something
goes wrong, they still won’t lose it.
To you and me, when we hear something is “lost
in space” we probably get a sense of dread
(and not just because of the terrible 1998
film).
It just seems too daunting a task to find
something that’s LOST IN SPACE.
But NASA’s got skillz.
And there’s nothing more hype than finding
something you thought was gone forever.
For example, Chandrayaan-1, an Indian Space
Research Organization probe currently orbiting
the moon, was just found by NASA’s Jet Propulsion
Laboratory!
It had been missing since 2009.
The ISRO lost contact with it, and they simply
couldn’t find it again, so they ended their
mission.
But then, JPL shot a large amount of microwaves
at the moon from a dish in California, and
picked them up in West Virginia.
They analyzed the bounce back, and found ol’
Chandy orbiting 200 kilometers above the moon.
Boop.
There it was.
It once was lost, but now is… well it’s
still lost, actually because they can’t
communicate with it, I guess?
That’s not typical.
These are computer systems, a big part of
the problem is pinpointing their exact location
at that point, you just give it a call and
(hopefully, it picks up).
This happened in a less gloriously scientific
way with a solar-research sat called STEREO-B
-- part of a pair: Stereo A and B. The twins
were programmed to fly around the sun and
take 3D pictures of mass ejections and flares.
Unfortunately, “B” was lost in 2014 when
scientists tested its reset function and it
just… never really came back.
They knew its orbit, and where it would be,
but couldn’t talk to it because the sun
was in the way, and it wasn’t responding
to their hails.
Fast-forward two years… scientists were
still tracking where it should be, and kept
sending messages its way and eventually, they
got lucky!
In 2016, Stereo-B came back online.
There was enough charge in its batteries,
and its antenna was pointing in the right
direction, so they got a ping back!
These computer systems are designed to live
in one of the harshest environments known
to man, they can be the size of small SUVs
like Curiosity, or an oven-sized cube like
Chandrayaan-1.
But space is big, and sometimes things get
lost.
If we’re lucky, and keep sending signals,
we hopefully build them smart enough to be
found.
There are so many stories of satellite rescue,
maybe you should make a website to catalog
them all!
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Have a science story you want us to look into
and tell?
Share your ideas with us on twitter at seeker,
and if you want a really incredible cow of
a tale -- check out this video about how vaccines
came from a cow.
Well, milkmaids.
Just watch it.
And subscribe for more stories on Seeker.